how to follow your dreams
i got a great question from one of my
newsletter subscribers love you guys
preeti who wrote in to say hey evan i'm
quite confident about my career i'm
unable to get my true call on my
interest in studios and future career
selection
right now i'm pursuing bachelor
technology in three years confused what
to do
i'm from the computer science branch and
i don't know programming what should i
do
i feel i want to learn programming
languages but i don't know where to
start please help me
following your dreams is hard
you're often fighting against the
logical
rational smart thing to do to chase this
opportunity
that doesn't make any sense but that
feels like the right thing to do
if you love computer programming if
that's your dream if that's what you
want to learn
then switch your courses and go for
computer programming
follow your dreams and that might be
scary
that might look like a failure in your
own eyes and society's eyes in your
family's eyes
you know jumping from course to course
jumping from job to job
doesn't look good right it's like this
person how do they not know what they
want to do
is seen as a sign of weakness but you
have to look at what the
alternative is what's the alternative
you know
right now that you don't want to be
doing what you're doing
if you continue on this path if you
don't learn about computer programming
that's your passion
you don't learn about that you're a
young person
you're in university you have the rest
of your life ahead of you
and you're about to embark on this path
that you don't love
that means you're going to be in a field
having a job
for the rest of your life doing
something that you don't love
are you ready to sign up for that the
other thing to think about
is regret i try to live my life without
regret
and what i don't want for you is for the
rest of your life
to wonder what would have happened
if i did the computer programming what
would my life be like
now if i took that course if i followed
my passion then
because the later you get on in life the
harder and harder and harder it is
the more responsibilities you have the
more difficult it is
to switch gears it's still possible but
it's harder
you're at a really important time in
your life
and you have to make the decision if you
have the courage
to follow your dreams or want to take
the safe route and do what everybody
else does
and just go get a job and something that
you might be good at not a lot of people
have that courage because it's hard
you're fighting against yourself you're
fighting against your family your
friends the people in your life
you're fighting against maybe you're
training and you have to decide
if you're gonna make a decision with
your head or your heart
i had the same challenge when i was in
university
and i've told this story a number of
times of people who are loyal viewers
i had to decide between having this high
paid job
80 to 100 000 a year traveling around
the world a job that i thought like a
few years ago i thought would have been
my dream job here it is my dream job
and in the meantime i hooked up with a
company
where i became an owner in it and was
was barely surviving making
300 a month and every smart
decision would have said go for that job
but
something didn't feel right my dream
at that time was to do this business
even it didn't make any sense i wasn't
making any money
i'm throwing away a huge opportunity to
work on what this thing that's not
working
but i didn't want to live my life with
regret to say what would have happened
if i focus on my business and i had this
passion for it that i had to follow
through on it even though it made
zero sense and i'm so glad that i did
that
because it's worked out i turned it
around we built a successful company
sold it started this i'm so grateful for
the life that i have
for that one decision that i made and it
wasn't easy it was hard it was one of
the hardest decisions i ever made in my
life
but i had the courage to follow through
on my dream
even though it didn't make logical sense
and if you want to live your life
you want to do something important you
want to feel fulfilled
then you have to do what's in your heart
and follow your dreams
and that may mean switching again you
know maybe it's computer programming you
get into that and
you know what that's not it maybe i want
to get into something else and if your
heart's taking you in that direction
then go for it and you may bounce around
and that's okay
because you have to bounce around until
you find the thing that you love doing
and are meant to do
that's when you're really going to be
happy that's when you're really going to
be successful
that's we're going to really be
fulfilled
so follow your dreams believe for those
of you watching like the video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment ask me a question
below make a video response
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel see more videos like this
thank you see you soon